Hello, Mr. Tanaka.
Welcome to Silicon Valley Software.
I'm Jack, VP of Sales.
Very nice to meet you.
I'm Takashi Tanaka, General Manager of Tokyo Technology.
It's nice to meet you as well.
Please call me Taka.
I'm Victoria, VP of Marketing.
It's great to finally meet you face to face.
After speaking so often on the phone, it's nice to "put a face with the voice".
Thank you for coming all the way from Japan to visit our company.
We've been looking forward to meeting you today.
How was the flight?
It was long, but very good.
I just arrived at San Francisco airport 3 hours ago.
Wow, you must be tired from the long flight.
Is the jet lag bothering you?
I'm fine. I was able to get some sleep on the airplane.
Would you like something to drink?
We have coffee, tea, soda and water here.
Oh, thank you.
I could use some coffee.
The caffeine will help me stay awake during the meeting.
Of course. My assistant will bring it for you right away.